q how does it feel to be back on the
universal life Oh horrifying I had PTSD
walking in here the the the the setup
here that she's referring to is the way
I show works on over has anybody seen it
will start here will go left we'll make
our way to the front give one reason why
you like the show describing the show
it's just we we we go out in public and
we mess around with each other we tell
you know we tell each other what to do
and if you don't do it at the end of the
episode you get a punishment so go back
for the universal tram story because I
know what it is but they don't know what
Universal story so here Universal they
have the famous tram ride that goes
around the whole the whole sets and
tours this is my punishment it wasn't
awesome it's like the subway where if an
emergency having someone drops his
cellphone they could pull the thing stop
the ride so what they made me do is stop
the ride seven eight times in an hour
and the first time people are forgiving
they're like oh poor guy dropped his
cellphone but then I had to stop the
ride and be like could you repeat that
and then by the seventh time that I
pulled that people were looking at me in
the eye and be like when we get off this
ride I'm gonna find you and I'm gonna
kill you like a four-year-old girl was
giving me the middle finger I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this